- And I open it up,
and the fucking smell
that comes out of 75 different
people's shit rags...
It's kind of like,
a cross between, like,
when Ghostbusters cross streams,
and, uh, and in Indiana Jones
when they open up
the Ark of the Covenant
and all the Germans
are like, "Augh!"
[dark electronic music]
[choking]
♪
[explosion]
[cheers and applause]
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening"!
I'm your host, Ari Shaffir!
Tonight all the stories
are about disasters.
Please welcome this next comic,
the host of the "Punch Drunk
Sports" podcast,
Mr. Ari Shaffir, everybody!
Okay, this is a quick story
about how I understood
the lyrics to a song
for the first time.
Um, I--last year
I went to China.
They told me two things--
I went for comedy--so they told
me two things before I went.
They gave me two rules.
First rule, they said, no
bringing drugs in of any kind,
because, they said,
it's punishable by death.
Yeah, and I was like, "fuck."
How much weed can I bring?
And they were like, "Ari!
None!"
And I was like, "Counter offer.
Some!"
And they were like,
"Don't do it!"
I'm like, "I'm bringing
pot cookies on the plane,
you can't stop me."
And I did.
And then we landed in Shanghai,
and I had like two pot cookies
left over so I just downed them
and had a great
first eight hours in Shanghai.
It was wonderful.
Here's what they don't tell you:
it's not punishable by death.
To traffic drugs
is punishable by death.
But if they just catch you
with them there,
it's very illegal.
It's still very illegal.
They'll kick you out
of the country.
That's what they'll do.
But I thought about it,
and it turns out that
I don't live in China, so...
Let's do it.
So fun--three weeks in China
for comedy.
Every once in a while,
every once in a while,
comedy really pays off.
All you got to do is
live in poverty for nine years.
And then you get your
free trip to China.
The cool thing is
is it's so illegal,
marijuana and all drugs there,
especially weed.
Once you do find weed there--
and I did find weed
'cause I'm a pothead
and that's what potheads do.
We find weed.
When you do find weed,
the cops in China
do not know
what marijuana smells like.
Yeah, it's just not around.
So this comedian in Beijing
showed me.
He goes, "Dude, you can smoke
pot right in front of them."
And he blew pot smoke
right at a cop.
I'm like,
"Are you out of your mind?"
He goes, "He's just thinks
you're smoking
tobacco for poor people."
And he's never smelled
that smell before.
The only way they can catch you,
literally, the only way they can
catch you is if you learn
the mandarin words for
"Officer,
we're smoking marijuana."
And my advice is
just don't learn those words.
They're not gonna help you.
The other rule they gave me
is they said, um, they said,
"No making fun of
the Chinese government."
No making any jokes about
Chinese government.
And I was like,
"I don't have any jokes about
Chinese government."
Fucking, get over yourself,
Chinese government.
Nobody's talking about you.
I've done comedy in Los Angeles,
New York, London, and Toronto,
and I've never heard a single
comedian do any jokes
about Chinese government.
'Cause it's way too
self-absorbed.
Here was a cool thing about
China--well, everything.
Here was the terrible thing,
and about all of Asia,
it's the toilet situation.
Yeah, so you know the seats
that go up and down
for men or women,
like that seat?
So they don't have that seat.
And then, they also, they don't
have the whole toilet.
They don't have any of it.
They don't have toilets.
They don't believe in it
or something.
They just got holes
in the ground.
I'm--literally--it's like
a regular bathroom floor,
with tiles and everything, and
then where the toilet should be
is just this hole.
And you're supposed to
go over it
like a college basketball coach
and you're just
supposed to squat.
You're just supposed to squat
and shit into this hole.
And they don't tell you at all.
They don't tell you
about any of it.
They just expect you to know,
so--and by the way,
in the hotels and stuff
they have regular toilets.
It's just in the rural parts.
So I was having a good time,
went to the Great Wall of China.
I went to--I went to visit
the Imperial Palace.
That was cool.
Nope--wait.
That's Star Wars.
"Imperial Palace," yeah,
that's for sure Star Wars, yeah.
What is--uh,
the Forbidden City!
That's what it is.
It's where the emperor lived.
And so I went there,
and I was walking around,
having a good time, and then
I got this important phone call
from my friend diarrhea.
And, um, that's when I really
started to hate China
because of this
toilet situation!
I run to the bathroom.
I'm just--sprint
to find the bathroom.
I burst open the door.
I'm telling you right now,
when you open up a stall door,
and there's no toilet in there,
your mind can't even wrap its
head around what's happening.
It's like some sort of
optical illusion.
You know, it's like,
"Which line is longer?"
You're like, "I don't know.
Top one?"
They're like, "No, same size!"
And you're like, "Bullshit.
Measure again."
Regular bathroom work--tiles
and then just fucking hole.
It looks like a union guy
was coming to install a toilet
and then he was like,
"Oh, lunchtime."
And then he just fucking left.
And they forgot
to get back to it.
I burst open the door
and I was like,
"Wha--oh, this one
must be under repair."
'Cause there's no toilet.
That's the one thing
you look for in a toilet,
is the toilet!
That's 95% of the experience,
is the actual toilet.
And I went to the next one,
I was like,
"This one--are they all
under repair?
Am I just missing the sign?"
And then I remembered like,
"Oh, they told me about these.
These fucking
shit-squat toilets."
That's what
you're supposed to do.
And I reali--
right then I was like,
"You know what,
I'm not doing this."
I was born an American
and I'll die an American.
And Americans sit down
when we shit.
That's our thing.
When they say,
"USA, number one."
They're talking about
number two.
We're number one
in number two.
And I was like,
"I'm out--I'm gone."
So I left, I walked out,
and I got like two steps away
and then diarrhea was like,
"Of course, you're doing it."
And I was like,
"Oh, yeah, diarrhea,
I forgot about you."
It gives you a break sometimes,
diarrhea, you know?
Diarrhea and the hiccups,
where you think they're gone
for a minute,
but then they ain't gone.
We're like,
"I got to shit so bad!
"I got to--what?
No.
"Oh, I might be okay.
"Never have I had to shit
so bad!"
So I go back into this--
into this stall,
I close the door.
Side note, by the way:
There's a trash can in there.
And all these--don't fucking
look in the trash can because,
uh, they don't flush
their toilet paper.
They throw it away.
[audience groans]
Yeah, and so they have
this trash can.
You know the--the little
office trash cans
that, like, spin?
The top spins.
You know, where it goes like--
and you can like hit it down
and it like...
I always try to hit it just
enough so it pops back up
and like go--
it's like a ride at Six Flags
where, you know...
And I open it up,
and the fucking smell
that comes out of 75 different
people's shit rags...
It's kind of like,
a cross between, like,
when Ghostbusters cross streams,
and, uh, and in Indiana Jones
when they open up
the Ark of the Covenant
and all the Germans
are like, "Augh!"
That's the smell
that comes out of this thing.
So I go into this fucking stall,
and I close the door.
And I'm looking at this hole.
Here's my first question:
how far do you
take your pants down?
I've done it, and I don't know
what the answer is.
I have no idea.
My first thought was like,
"Take them down to your ankles."
'Cause that's how
I'd normally do it.
But then you can't do that
because here's the deal,
I went down,
I took them down to my ankles,
and then I, like, lined it up.
And I'm like,
"Hold on a second."
Like, "My asshole
"is directly above my pants.
"How am I not gonna
shit into my pants?
"Unless a heavy gust
of wind comes by,
I'm for sure gonna
shit into my pants."
And by the way,
I thought about it
and I realized that
shitting into your pants
is actually a lot worse
than shitting in your pants.
You'd think they'd be
the same thing, right?
They're not the same thing.
Shitting into your pants
is a holocaust
compared to shitting
in your pants.
'Cause if you
shit in your pants--
and let's be honest,
a lot of us have done that,
am I--am I not wrong?
Like, I mean like
after ninth grade.
It happens!
Whatever, you're drinking
and you sneeze.
That's not your fault.
That's just destiny.
But what do you do
when that happens?
I know what I do.
I go home.
I go home 'cause I'm a grown man
and I have shit in my pants
and I can't be out
with other people.
Just can't; I can't be out with
people with shit in my pants.
I think about it, usually,
for a second, like,
"How much shit is in there?"
you know.
Like it goes through my head,
and then I realize
it doesn't matter,
it does not matter.
There could be a shart
and it could be an unloading.
Either way, I'm a grown-up
and I have shit in my pants
and I can't be out
with other people.
No matter what I'm doing,
I could be in line at a movie,
and I'll be like, "Hey,
you guys, that's so funny I--
"Achoo!
Oh--
I'll see you guys later."
They're like, "What?
Where are you going?
You wanted to see the movie."
I'm like, "Yeah, I don't
want to see it anymore.
You tell me how it was."
And just fucking slowly...
Just real slowly walk away.
You don't want to jostle at all,
you know what I mean?
Just even steps.
It's just gonna be a little bit
warmer than it was before.
[audience groans]
Yeah, that's if you
shit in your pants.
But if you shit
intoyour pants,
well then, you got to not
have those pants on.
And then you got to
work up the courage...
The suicide-like courage,
to put the dirty diaper
back on yourself.
And you know it's gonna
squoosh in there,
like you're making a mold
for a retainer.
So anyway, it's not down
to your ankles, I don't think.
And by the way, the one time
you want handicap bars
to hold onto,
they don't have handicap bars.
They make you be
fucking Zen about it.
And you just got to fucking
use your core.
So I don't know
what the answer is.
They don't help you in any way,
by the way.
There's no diagram.
There's no fucking help
along the way.
Everything has a diagram on it!
A hand dryer in a bathroom,
fucking, a big machine that's
right next to the sink
with one button
right in the middle.
They're like, "No,
you'll never figure this out."
So they put
a little cartoon on it
of somebody pushing the button
and then somebody else
drying their hands,
or taking the bacon.
That's a hand dryer.
Chinese shit-squat toilet?
Nah, figure it out.
It's intuitive.
So I have no idea.
I didn't know what to do.
So here's what I did.
I don't know if this
is right or wrong,
but I took my shirt off.
And you know the hook that's on
the door of the bathroom stalls?
I just sort of hooked it
on there, and then I...
[audience clapping]
Lowered myself.
And I just kind of
did it that way.
Feels like I shit right now.
[laughs]
Yeah, I don't know if
that's the right answer or not,
but that's what I did.
It seemed to work.
It seemed to work, I mean,
I shit that way, so...
I felt good too.
When I did it, I was like,
"Fuck, yeah.
I live like
a real Chinese person."
And I finished
and it feels great.
When you shit like this,
by the way,
it's aw--it clears you out
from the neck all the way down.
It's like you're a new man.
Have you ever done it?
It feels wonderful.
I do it now when I get home.
I'll stand on my toilet seat,
and then I'll fucking squat over
just for old time's sake.
Like a POW who's got to sleep
underneath the bed
once in a while.
And I did it, and I felt great.
I felt wonderful.
I was very careful
not to let my balls
touch the fu--surface
of the thing.
'Cause I have--I have
very long balls,
and they'll occasionally touch
the water level of a toilet.
And if there's one place
I want my balls to never touch
it's the inside of a
Chinese shit-squat toilet.
So anyway, I finish,
and I was like,
"Yeah, I did it,"
and I got up to wipe,
and that's when I found out that
they don't offer toilet paper
in China.
[audience groans]
Yeah, they don't believe in it.
I think their theory is:
you're the one shitting,
you clean it up.
And that's not wrong!
It's not even that it's wrong!
I'm just saying,
you should warn people.
You should let people know.
Like everyone who lands at the
airport with a round eye,
they should give them
a pamphlet, and be like,
"Here, you're
gonna have some problems."
Just figure it out.
I'm standing there; I'm like,
"What am I gonna to do?"
Well anyway, here's the deal.
Five days before,
I landed in Shanghai,
it's the first place I got to,
I got there in the morning.
Uh, I got to a club, the first
place I performed, this bar.
And the club owner was like,
the bar owner was like, um,
"Oh, you just got here today?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And he goes, "Oh!"
And he gave me
this packet of tissue paper.
You know those little
travel Kleenex packs?
And he gave me one of those,
and he goes,
"Here.
You'll need this."
It was like Gandalf had come up
to me or something, you know.
And I was like,
"What will I need it for?"
And he just goes,
"You'll know."
And--but he was right, though.
He was right.
I was standing there
at that fucking toilet
at the--at Forbidden City,
and I was like,
"What am I gonna--
[frantic mumbling]
I got the toilet paper!"
[indistinct yelling]
I was so excited.
Here's the problem, though,
they don't give you
unlimited tissue paper
in one of those things.
They give you six.
They give you six pieces
of tissue paper.
With six, you can't
be an American anymore.
You can't be like,
"Ah, four at a time.
"I love to waste.
"Most resources in the world.
USA, USA!"
Not with six.
With six you got to budget.
You got to make every one count.
You got to start like
way from the bottom
and then go all the way up
to about here.
Fold.
Go back, start from the bottom.
Now we're here.
I kept doing that:
Start from the bottom, now here.
And that's when I realized what
that Drake song was all about.
[dark electronic music]
[cheers and applause]
♪